hi there steve here again
uh i'm going to talk a bit about my
korean studies and i want to talk again
about
the issue of input and language learning
and literacy first of all i've spent uh
probably about an hour and a half
working on my ipad reading content
uh korean content in in link in ilink in
the app and i've been doing a lot of
highlighting of phrases because then
these phrases and i try as i highlight
the phrase i try to highlight something
that i think will reappear something
that i think is a phrase that is so
common
not specific to this context but
somewhat of a general phrase that i'm
like to see it likely to see it again
and in fact i often do and so it helps
me to kind of focus in on handy phrases
that are repeatable and that i can use
in the language
so i'm continuing with my input based
activities largely with regard to korean
i've hardly spoken at all i'm going to
try to line up a couple of conversations
next week i want to talk about the
the
language conference in boston
and i went over my notes again
and i went through their brochure of all
the presenters and stuff
and at the end of my little talk i'm
going to ramble for quite a while here
i'm going to see if i can add on some of
my videos from the conference to give
you a sense of the mood as i say it was
lots of enthusiastic teachers uh
i enjoyed it
and if i look at some of the main themes
there obviously one was technology
people all
were embracing technology
how useful it is i don't know it looks
like google and their suite of products
for the classroom are taking over
because they're offered free of charge
and enables the students to connect with
each other and the idea is that we now
live in this era of 21st century
literacy or new literacy and we should
uh help the kids you know engage with
all this technology or the kids already
have it and we have to in the classroom
the teachers have to accommodate them
i'm not convinced that it's all that
useful and i will explain
why but anyway that was one um
feature and it kind of ties into this
other thing that came up all the time
and that is classroom activities in
other words the teachers are constantly
looking at what can they do
in the classroom which is
understandable because they have 25 30
35 kids in the classroom they have to
find something for the kids to do so
they have
you know they have them making videos
editing videos sharing videos using
some google platform to do it uh they
have various forms of guided reading
guided conversations
getting the students to talk about uh
whatever they've been doing
um
so i mean that and that's fine as far as
it goes
however
and then there was also a there was a
lot of discussion of testing and
evaluation and how best to evaluate kids
and so we have them doing these
activities and then we evaluate their
performance and so forth and so on now i
assume that
the same kind of discussion
uh takes place with regard to all
subjects that are taught at school in
other words much of the discussion is
about technology activities in the
classroom
and evaluation
however
when we consider
that 80 percent or some such number
of people who are in prison
read at a grade four level
that half of the kids that attend
university in
the united states and presumably canada
is the same
uh
require remedial english
when we consider that
i don't know 30 40 percent of the
population again in north america has
abort a very low level of functional
literacy
when we consider how important you know
good literacy literacy skills are
how the people with the highest 20 30
literacy skills have the best incomes
jobs
whatever
uh and and that's not to say that people
with poor literacy skills can't be
successful i've worked with people who
have poor literacy skills and who are
very good at what they do and they're
not
less valuable human beings for the fact
that they don't read very well but
the reality is that in
education in the workplace statistically
you're more likely to be successful if
you read well and it's also been shown
that kids who have poor reading skills
at grade one two three they never catch
up
so with all of the google
technology and planned activities and
enthusiastic teachers in fact
people a lot of people don't learn to
read very well and that might be the
major contributor to inequality
unemployment crime and other social ills
that cost the society a lot of money and
of course can be quite
devastating for the people involved so i
ask myself how effective is all of this
technology and concern about activities
and all the well-intended and i might
add into that this whole teaching people
critical thinking and intercultural
skills and and all this other social
linguistics and all that stuff
when the fundamental issue is
and and there was a presenter who who
made the point that really everything we
learn
is based on our literacy skills and
literacy skills means words
if you don't have words you can't read
and so uh
and in fact
i've seen studies in the past that
showed that
math and science courses require a
higher degree of literacy a more complex
you know
vocabulary the lexical index of those
science and math texts is higher so if
people struggle to read they will
struggle with math and they will
struggle with science so reading skills
are so fundamentally important and i
think there's a real relationship
between teaching foreign languages and
teaching literacy in the native language
both relate to
a lot of input and a lot of words so
this brings us to the subject of input
and here there were various discussions
about you know people another buzzword
was authentic content so you know
teachers were looking for things like
youtube videos ads
uh you know stuff written on shopping
bags
um on receipts
so i'm saying to myself okay on the one
hand they're talking about authentic
content on the other hand crashing talks
about compelling input now would we read
receipts shopping bags
uh
and advertisements in english is that
compelling input for us in our own
language i don't think so why would they
because it's exotic it comes from this
other language that we're learning why
does that become compelling input one
presenter talked about some ad about
brushing your teeth and that would be a
great in for a discussion in the class
where we can really focus on
uh you know
oh no it was on washing your hands and
so then we can focus on all kinds of
things that relate to washing your hands
and the difference between a flu and a
cold and stuff but why is that
necessarily compelling for a student i
don't know
uh compelling input
uh and and i i agree with that with the
concept that as long as you expose
people to things that are interesting to
them and accessible and here again a
concept that came up was the zone of
proximal
difficulty now there is something that's
not too difficult for you and if it's
meaningful for you and if you're
interested in it you're going to learn
the language
if you read and i would add listening
because the two go together and i think
that is true for foreign language
learning and it's true for literacy
development let people choose what
they're interested in something's just a
that's just a little bit difficult for
them and away they go
and as krashen and van patten pointed
out and i thought this was quite a an
interesting
statement
where
van patten said accuracy is a byproduct
of language acquisition
not the cause of the acquisition so once
you acquire the language through massive
reading and listening you then have a
chance to become more accurate in your
use of the language insofar as grammar
is concerned or in
in
also a more accurate use of words
and i might add that when i correct
english very often it's it's not so much
grammar as in grammar rules that are a
problem but just the inaccurate use of
words those that is not the word we
would use for that so again vocabulary
and i've said it many times is a key to
accuracy
in a foreign language and in your own
language
so
where i'm coming with all of this is and
and of course yeah i wanted to add to
this zone of proximate difficulty like
just that little bit difficult that's
sometimes described as as one plus n
you know this can vary from person to
person uh myself if i'm studying on link
i want 10 to 20
unknown words so that i can grow my
vocabulary more quickly if i had to rely
on material that was just a little bit
difficult with only two or three percent
or five percent unknown words it would
take me forever to grow my vocabulary uh
one other thing is when it comes to
activities in the classroom
i like
activities that are easy
that don't force me to think
that is that zone of proxima difficulty
just a little difficult but easy so
pyotr with his real polish at
realpolish.pl
he asks you questions
uh about the text or the story that he's
told
but he gives you the answer before he
asks you
so you don't have to scratch your brain
to find the answer you just have to
remember it for a couple of seconds and
then repeat it back to him
i think that's part of the success of
duolingo
you don't learn a lot but whatever
you're doing is relatively easy to do
and i think this is a lesson for us at
link we've got to introduce
more of that kind of activity which
gives people a sense of satisfaction and
achievement they feel good about
themselves
uh but what we really want them to do is
go to go back to continue listening and
reading and if we can train learners to
become independent learners and that
means in the case of
school children if we can spend the
first two three years of schooling
making sure that every kid is a good
reader for his or her age in other words
forget the other
learning social skills or learning you
know dancing around whatever they do in
grade one
uh
just focus on reading and i think there
are ways of making that interesting the
a let them choose the stories that
interest them give them audio with the
text i even think the kinds of
statistics that we generate at link with
how many words they've learned little
ding-dongs going off as they achieve
different milestones
assuming they have an ipad of course but
without that some other way of making
the absolute focus for the first three
years that there should be no child that
goes from grade three to grade four that
doesn't have a significant vocabulary
and i think the method the technology is
there to do that and that is far more
important than getting kids and getting
kids to
uh make videos edit videos post stuff to
facebook and all this other stuff
teaching them 21st century literacy
whatever i'll i think all of that is a
bit of a smoke screen
and and this
detracts us or distracts us from the
fundamental task of ensuring
that
that in our society people learn to read
because once they can read well they can
learn on their own or if they're in a
school or university they have a chance
to to actually follow what's being
taught to read up to enrich their
knowledge and stuff because
most of the knowledge at least academic
knowledge we have to acquire and that
includes languages from outside we don't
have it inside we've got to acquire it
through massive listening and reading
and if we don't have the skills
uh if we don't have a vocabulary we
can't even listen we don't understand
what's being said
and
and so i go back to what crash and says
and that is that compelling input
a little bit difficult
depending on
your
ability to cope with difficult and i
fully recognize that as an experienced
language learner i can deal with
you know vagueness uncertainty
uh fuzziness in
my text where someone who is less
confident may want to be
more you know they want to understand
everything before they move on
but um maybe there again we can persuade
them that that's not necessary even for
someone reading in their own language
they kind of 80 understood it that's
good if you enjoy it that's keep keep
reading and just let the brain gradually
adjust to this input of language and and
increase your ability to to cope with
language and once you do that then your
ability to output will come along so a
bit of a ramble i went well past it and
then it's going to be even longer if i
tack on these uh videos from boston but
that's what i wanted to get off my chest
so
now get my handy dandy remote thing here
and we'll shut this down i hope
no that didn't shut it down hi there
it's day three
behind me is the original
site of the boston tea party i'm having
a great time in boston i like the city
and i'm heading off to have a cup of
coffee and a fun
before i start day three
and i got my goofy
southwestern france
world rugby tournament 2007
bereon
keep the sun out of my eyes
bye for now
hi there here i am about to enter
the language convention here fortunately
i arrived at dave early
and we didn't have these enormous
lineups to get in
but uh looking forward and just
just to get us in the mood
here is this african
up here you think i'm taller than i am
because you're down there and
this makes you makes you look up
okay um i'm glad that steve went first
because
um so basically
publishers
is
china's big
chinese
and this is the booth
and there is carol explaining the people
lots of interest
in your material
graded readers for various languages
very impressive it's going towards more
comprehensive
two years well you just started yes